[Music]
hello everyone
conrad moffat black baron black of cross
harbor
kcsg born 25th of august 1944
is a canadian-born newspaper publisher
financier
and writer he is the author of 10 books
mostly dealing with canadian and
american history including biographies
of quebec
premier maurice du plessis and u.s
presidents franklin roosevelt
richard nixon and donald trump as well
as two memoirs
he's currently writing a political
history of the ancient world
concentrating primarily
on the romans and the greeks his father
was businessman george montague black
ii who had significant holdings in
canadian manufacturing retail
and media businesses through part
ownership of the holding company
ravelston corporation in 1978
two years after their father's death
conrad and his older brother montague
took
majority control of ravelston over the
next seven years
they sold off most of their non-media
holdings to focus on newspaper
publishing
black controlled hollinger international
once the world's third largest english
language newspaper empire
which published the daily telegraph in
the uk the chicago sun times the
jerusalem post
the national post in canada and hundreds
of community newspapers across north
america
before controversy erupted over the sale
of some of the company's assets he is
one of canada's
most recognizable and influential
figures
and has known many of the great
political actors and cultural figures
of the last half century it's my great
pleasure to have him as a guest today
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
with me today
not at all jordan always a pleasure to
speak with you yeah well it's very nice
to see you again it's been a couple of
years since we've had the pleasure of
speaking and so
i'm glad we have this opportunity even
though it's mediated by electronics
i missed you so let's i want to talk to
you
biographically essentially i'd like to
walk through your life and so
let's start as far back as we can tell
tell me about your childhood if you
would and
what stands out for you in relationship
to your parents and
um well while i was born in montreal
my parents moved here to toronto when i
was uh
very young not even a year old and um
just at the end of world war ii and and
uh we
we lived in what was then just the edge
of metropolitan toronto beyond us were
farms and that was
up uh for those of your
viewers who know toronto right after the
bayview avenue passes uh york university
uh glendon campus and the granite club
uh and crescent school just beyond that
was where we lived and that was the
outer limit of the city uh
in terms of the built up area and uh
so there weren't many young people
around
you know to visit with in the
neighborhood so the result was that i
spent more time i think it was the
beginning of the television era everyone
had a television set but they just got
it
in the last few years and there were
only a few channels on the air and
for the most part you had either those
funny antennas sitting on top of the
receiver or
or antenna on the roof of your house
and um so i spent a lot of time reading
and and and that was how i developed my
interest in history and i started
reading about
interesting historical personalities and
my father although he was a
successful businessman had been a a very
uh accomplished academic as far as he
went
but that was in the 30s and his
father came under great financial
pressure so my my father became a
chartered accountant
in the theory that there was he put no
such thing as an unemployed chartered
accountant
and in those days people really had to
think in terms of
how could they how could they do things
that made it
as likely as possible that they would be
able to make
an income and provide you know and
afford to get married and provide for
families
uh and you know it was a much more
financially pressurized era than it is
now and
and that he graduated in 1937
and we were starting as a society to
recover from the depression by then
but there were still huge numbers of
unemployed and he had to set aside his
academic interests but
with that said he was a he was a
particularly i was particularly
fortunate in having him apart from
anything else
as as a parent who encouraged that
historical interest and knew
rather a lot about many of the things
that i
uh you know that i took an interest in
early on and then as a
a a really a remarkable gesture my
parents took my brothers just the two of
us in the family
took my brother and myself to britain in
1953 at the time of the coronation
and and we you know we've toured around
all these
monuments it was still the war damage in
london was still very evident then so we
we saw what the war was like from much
closer than
anyone experienced it in north america
and uh
and uh you know i i remembered as
very young people do remember uh you
know visiting
uh the duke of wellington's house and
saint paul's cathedral and things like
this
and uh so i always had an interest in
history and was
encouraged uh by my parents my father in
particular
and and that was that was a that
i think that was the only thing that was
pretty clean
if not exactly noteworthy a bit
different from
most of the people i went to school with
because they lived
closer into town and had more social
time
than i did so you speak of your father
fondly by the sounds of it it sounds to
me like he was an encouraging figure in
your life from a very young age is that
a reasonable
presumption yes i know i i remember
both my parents very fondly my father uh
in this scenario i wouldn't want to for
obvious reasons get into
too much but later on he became
at times a slightly depressive
personality
and and his career was something of an
anti-climax he he
did very well and and made a
significant amount of money and he had
he was working with i mean with slash
four
uh very famous canadian industrialist ep
taylor and in the brewing business and
he was the
chief executive of what was then the
largest
well one of the largest brewing
companies in the world but certainly the
largest in canada
it was called canadian breweries limited
in those days
and um
he had a disagreement on policy with mr
taylor
and he said look instead of um
instead of having an argument with this
i i i've done this job now for 10 years
and i and i i don't need the salary
i i don't need it to live in the way
i've become accustomed to
so i will retire now it's probably time
for change after 10 years you
do whatever you want with the company
and we remain
friends and don't strain our relations
and that's what happened and they
remained friends
to the to the end of his life um and
uh but so he he he he retired at the age
of 47
and he was a well-to-do man he didn't
lack for anything in the material way
but the balance of his life nearly 20
years
was an anti-climax he just sat in his
house and read and
saw a steadily slowly but steadily
declining number of people
and uh and he just never did anything
particularly after that i don't mean
that he should have charged out and got
a job that that's not for me to say and
wouldn't
wouldn't have served any purpose anyway
unless he was particularly enthused
about it but
someone like it's a i found it's a
perfectly good thing and often a very
uh renovating thing to change
careers but but and i'm sure you would
in your experience know this and believe
the same thing it is a bad thing
to simply do nothing just sit in a
rocking chair
uh that that leads to a a steady
and accelerated level of decline
and that unfortunately is what happened
to my father i mean he
was 65 when he died but but uh which
which is not really a good lottery
ticket nowadays but um
but it was an anti-climax but but he
always was an interesting man i would
even even after uh you know i left i
moved
out of the house to go to university
when i was
uh uh gee i was only 18 and apart from
that apart from one year i didn't live
with my parents again but i was in
toronto
much of the time and and i always saw
them a lot
um and and and it was always interesting
always had a good relationship i had a
somewhat turbulent
period my teens and looking back on it
uh
i can see that my parents treated me
with uh
greater patience and than probably i
would if i were in their position
and uh but i i i believe that
uh you know that was just a phase in our
last uh the last five years they
my parents died only only ten days apart
and um
uh the our last
ten years or so couldn't have been more
cordial
you know well i was curious about your
father because i'm i'm
i'm curious psychologically about the
role that fathers in particular play
in relationship to encouraging their
children which seems to me a primary
paternal role
and so when when i see someone who's
successful
at and and and
who who i suspect in some sense isn't
intrinsically rebellious in their
central spirit maybe that's wrong
i'm always curious about their
relationship with their father i mean
you started to read early you were
reading history
he obviously did did he push books your
way did he guide your reading how did
that all
sometimes uh he he in particular he gave
me
when i was 13. he
handed me a book and he said obviously
it's not for me to tell you what to read
but i do recommend this and if you just
read a few pages in it
i think you will want to continue and it
was a.g mcdonald's
book napoleon and his marshals to people
interested in napoleon's a very famous
book
and for example one of the great tomes
on napoleon david chandler's the
campaigns of napoleon a book of
1300 pages of tremendous work of
scholarship and very well written
in the in the forward credits eg
mcdonald and and
people who write about napoleon often do
it's a tremendously readable book and
and and and and it it
gave me a a huge interest napoleon that
that i've kept up you know i mean after
a while you
you feel you know enough about somebody
but but uh but it it it was a great um
uh it was a great uh uh encouragement
and incitement
and and confirmation of the intrinsic
interest in studying these
very interesting personalities of the
past and
he did a number of things like that and
in slightly different fields
another one some years later two or
three years later
he he gave me a copy of
uh nancy mitford's pursuit of love now
it's a novel
but about real people but the names
changed
and um and it was a particular
satisfaction to me
in in later years when i was living in
britain and was the
chairman of the daily telegraph and i
met a lot of these people
my nancy mitford unfortunately had died
but uh
her sisters the duchess of devonshire i
knew and the uh
lady mosley the widow of sir oswald
mosley the fascist leader
i i met her and jessica mitford who was
married to a communist
very eccentric british family and so a
wide
gap in their political abuse and um uh
nancy midford herself was had a
tremendous uh
torrid romance with one of the most
prominent figures in the entourage of
general de gaulle
and uh when he was the president of the
fifth republic and
and uh and prior to that and um
uh so these book i just cite those two
in particular but
they were tremendously readable
interesting books and and they did
launch my interest in different fields
he did that a number of times but
he was never oppressive or or or
dogmatic about it and actually quite
subtle i remember um
my parents took us on easter holiday in
1955 so i was 10 years old
my brother's four years older out to the
west coast by train
and back but but we got around a bit in
the west coast
and um on the train my father gave us a
reward
if we would memorize lincoln's address
at gettysburg now it's only 10 sentences
you know
it's not that hard to memorize it and we
did but
but it did incite my interest in mr
lincoln and of course he's
one of the great and arresting figures
of modern history as well
so yes he did that i i i there you put
me in mind
no doubt if this was the chief focal
point of our discussion i could
identify a good many other things but i
i i cite
those ones and by the way on the nancy
midford piece
a house that is referred to in um
a pursuit of love is one that they love
to go to because unlike their own house
it wasn't drafty it wasn't that
eccentric
british rural nobilities terribly
uncomfortable house without
real hot water and and then that kind of
thing
it was just a very comfortable house
with central heating and so on and
it turned out that a friend of mine
rented it and we went out
there to lunch a few times and it was i
mean i
i couldn't explain it in a way that
would be of any interest to anyone that
was there other than my wife
but it was it was as if i'd been there
before from having read about it it was
just a very interesting
connection with my past how old were you
when you started to read seriously
i i started when i was nine or ten i
remember
reading i remember
reading the first volume of general the
goals war memoirs when they were first
published in english
they're the ones that begin all my life
i've thought of france in a certain way
and uh it's beautifully written by that
i mean de gaulle was a wonderful writer
he's not always historically reliable
but political memoirists rarely are
i mean the same could be said of mr
churchill but he he's a
lovely writer and uh um
uh and so from then on i i was i wasn't
writing
i mean for a while i read the boys book
of the navy and i i think
i think we went through the hardy boys
and that kind of thing for
approximately one month when i was seven
or eight but i moved on to
the history of the navy or some sports
figures you know like ted williams or
something like that
and then i got into i got into the
history thing when i was nine and
stayed at it after that so
how much how much were you reading when
you were a kid and say 90. well
i wasn't a fast reader but i was i was a
retentive reader so when i read
something i tended to remember it well
and you know a couple of hours a day
every day
and then a little more on the weekends
when would you do that before you went
to bed did you have a routine yes
yeah pretty much yeah i know i'd have
you know i was supposed to do my
homework and there were some television
programs that i watched that
i liked but yeah i wasn't one of these
young people who was just
stuck glued in front of a screen every
every free moment the way a lot of
youngsters nowadays are with the video
games and things i
i wasn't like that i mean it is possible
and i
look jordan as you and i know there are
hundreds of millions of people in the
world who do sit staring at a television
set all day
but i i and and they're all as long as
we've had television there have been
people who've been
thoroughly captivated by it but i was
always rather more choosy in programming
i
i mean i liked uh intro
things like war victory at sea you know
it's a drama but the us navy
uh yeah that was a great series i know
that series it's it gets great
and with richard rodgers music was
really taken from vogue
powerful beginning showing the the the
the aerial shots of the pacific fleet
these this
colossal maybe moving forward but um
and some of the humorous programs like
the honeymooners with jackie gleason i
like but
but i i would i would know a program to
watch and go and watch it for half an
hour and then go back and read something
i wouldn't just sit there
waiting for whatever came next and were
you up all night with
with flashlight under the covers reading
not all night
but often a little bit and it has to be
said that
my parents were not overly authoritarian
it was a relatively large house i could
my mother would come up once in the
course of the night and
make sure everything was fine but i i i
i
i normally hear her coming but in any
case they didn't get particularly
excited about
about my reading with a flashlight
because they correctly assumed the
9 or 10 or 11 year old would fall asleep
anyway so
you know when he felt like it so any
idea what it is about history in
particular that attracted you because
obviously you you have an intrinsic
interest in it
you didn't even gravitate towards
fiction when you were a child you you
gravitated towards non-fiction and
history pretty fast so
what is this i went on a binge
of fiction in university
uh and when i started as one does you
know
i mean i find i found that with my own
uh
uh sons and daughter and and uh
you know you you you suddenly become
interested in writing
and you read a lot that he wrote then
you're on to the next one you know so in
that way
uh you know i read a huge number of
novels by famous novelists
and is that is that what you did you'd
find a novelist you really liked and
then read everything and then
move on to someone else basically and
especially the americans you know scott
fitzgerald and ernest hemingway and john
steinbeck and so on
uh and uh and the latter two were alive
and i was reading about them or reading
their words and um
uh but but but i got into others but not
as
comprehensive i mean i think i read four
or five of the books of
uh
george eliot and uh uh
uh in the most well you know the number
of
uh factory and um uh
you know the obvious ones
and so what what was it about history do
you think that that attracted you so
much and so young
um because
many i mean the personalities i was
reading about were terribly interesting
they had extraordinary careers
and and it it started to give me
um this sounds ludicrous here you you
may you and your
viewers may conclude that i'm a
psychiatric case or something but it's
not as if i
identified at all with say a man like
napoleon
it's just that in his career you could
see
points where absolutely everything was
at risk
and he persevered successfully and
points where
he he he was you know fortune had not
smiled upon him and
and it things looked terribly bleak and
then suddenly things opened up now it
was a revolutionary time
unlike canada in the 50s and 60s i mean
you could scarcely
think of a less revolutionary place and
and um
uh but the the pattern of events where
people's fortunes change so quickly
and in both directions i mean of course
napoleon ended up in santolina
but but um he actually attempted to
commit suicide after he came back from
russia
and um and
and if we were referring earlier to
abraham lincoln there were there were
moments where
everything appeared to be terribly
gloomy appeared to be a failure
was it was widely mocked for a variety
of reasons
including his physical appearance which
which in photographs is actually rather
impressive
but um but it it appeared to be
hopeless and that he was consigned to
being
a a failure who had who had tried to
prevent
the breakup of this country
unsuccessfully and had propagated a war
that was not successful
and and of course it all turned
and and and you you you end up
appreciating the qualities of these
people both
those who emulate and those to try to
avoid now in
mr lincoln's case it's a particularly
striking example because it is almost
impossible to find something negative to
say about
him he was a self-made man but with none
of that
chippiness itself made people up and had
he was a
genuine intellectual but an autodidact
and and uh but never with any of the
pomposity or dogmatism of some
intellectuals
and and he he he
he was always saddened rather than angry
at the many betrayals and
disappointments he suffered
and while he was a rather morose man in
some ways he had a splendid sense of
humor
he had a terribly difficult life and had
two sons die as boys
and and this tragedy did not these
tragedies and
afflictions didn't
didn't compromise his ultimate sense of
optimism
and uh uh he was he was really a
remarkably admirable character as well
as the extremely effective statesman
and of course he he was a wonderful
wordsmith
i mean you we were talking about the
gettysburg address i noticed
when i first read it under the
incitement to memorize it
that for example where he said uh
um fondly well
you know he said for those who
here gave their lives that that nation
might live
i mean just to use the same word as the
noun and the verb in the same sentence
is slightly artistic you know
and in the second inaugural when he said
uh fondly do we hope
fervently do we pray that this mighty
scourge of war may speedily pass away i
mean that
that is in fact the line of poetry
he he was a remarkable wordsmith
and you were you were noticing that the
way that words were crafted as well when
you were
reading history uh not
not as well as one does after a bit of
practice but
you know you i started to notice and
then started to look for it you know
so and all right so you were reading
well in vance
well in advance of your years what was
it like for you going to school when you
were
let's let's go when you were a child
again before you went to university
well i think i i was you know you always
did the necessary to
to be um on the same
wavelength if you will as your friends
you know i didn't want to be thought of
as a
i didn't mind being thought of as
slightly eccentric i didn't want to be
thought of as an
odd person and in fairness
a lot of a lot of the other students
were
interested in a lot of things i i went
to relatively
i guess relatively um
good schools i mean i didn't like them
very much but uh but i loved university
but i didn't like school very much but
um
uh is is and i remember
in 1958 i was 13 and because it was well
known that
i was interested in france when the
disturbances came in the spring of that
year
at the end of the fourth republic the uh
our class teacher asked me if i would
because this was this was on the front
pages of the newspapers and led the news
every night you know the
return of the goal from colombia in 58
um
and the threat of the revolt by the army
and algerian
and the teacher asked me if i would
give a five minute comment on it the
following day so i did
and and i'm you know i was careful to
try and not
be pompous or and not get into obscure
things
and and i don't mean to put on the heirs
of somebody who was any
in fact great authority in these matters
but um
i i i i i was i was flattered that he
asked and i
and i made an effort to try and make it
interesting and and it was appreciated
and i it was it was one of those
little experiences in life that was very
positive and
reassuring to me that these my
classmates didn't think i was just a
kook you know
because they were reading about it too
and they were in a way saying well you
know what's going on in france
i mean in in canada and britain and the
united states
you know you didn't have the army
threatening to
return to the capital by you can take
over the country
and everybody going out into the country
uh 120 miles to talk to a retired
general but
whether he wanted to take over the
government or not i mean that this
we didn't have that english-speaking
country so it was a bit different
do you remember anything of your
ambitions at that time
well here i must say i was somewhat
influenced by my father's emilia
toronto in those days was if i may say
it without i hope sounding like an old
dowager or something
a terribly plain
austere place it there wasn't any flair
to it
it had nice residential areas but but it
wasn't a good-looking city at all
although until the first subway was
opened in the mid
50s uh all the wires were above grounds
you had these
creosotes soaked um
blackened telephone poles everywhere
weighted down thick clusters of wires
and an inordinate amount of that old
sort of victorian
reddish but not red brick or the color
of queen's park
but with you know with the dust of years
on it
apart from a few individual buildings
like the um
old bank of commerce for example and
osgood all
and some others there weren't many nice
looking buildings downtown it was not a
nice looking city the way montreal was
or let alone
new york or something and um
and and they're you know it was a
virtuous place but it was a terribly
sober place you know you couldn't
go to the cinema on sundays there wasn't
a sunday newspaper
now i of course was just a boy and i
didn't drink or anything but
if older people um
many cousins of mine who were older
sunday they wanted to go out with a date
they had to go to a to a hotel to find
a restaurant that was licensed i mean
it was that only changed with john
roberts in the 60s and
so my father's friends
businessmen as far as i could see were
the only
people that had any sort of style you
know
mr taylor and mr mcdougall and colonel
phillips who was the
chancellor of the university uh that he
was associated with them and others who
were friends like john
best and so on they they had some style
they had some claire and they were
wealthy but but in a tasteful way and
that
you know so that it was kind of an
attractive thing to
aspire to be wealthy and and
and and enjoy it but in a tasteful way
you say i mean mr taylor
built the jockey club it was just a
bunch of milk wagon horses and fixed
races until he took it
took it over and fixed it up and you
know made it a great horse racing
operation and um
so i so i was sort of attracted to the
idea of getting
into business in a way that i could uh i
could raise my uh
you know raise my net worth and standard
of living
but but all was i i had a
if not exactly an academic interest
certainly a
an interest to study history and
potentially to write something
although although it took me a long time
to summon the courage to write anything
yeah so you've covered your interest in
history and now we've delved into a
little bit into the
origins of your interest in business so
that does leave that third
issue hanging to some degree so let's go
to to the time when you went to
university
you you said you read a tremendous
amount of fiction in university what did
you major in
and what was it like for you how do you
remember your university experience
uh very fondly uh i went first to ottawa
pardon me to the to carlton university
and um
i had a somewhat um robustus career in
high school
and changed schools number of times and
finally
i came if if i may just back up slightly
so
if if anyone is interested in my story
this is an interesting part of it i
i it's not for me to say whether it is
in the abstract interesting or not
but um in grade 13
i finally concluded that these schools
were so incompetent
and most of the teachers in them were so
incompetent and in addition malicious
some of them
that i discovered that you could in fact
write your matriculation examinations
on your own you didn't have to do it in
school
so i informed my father that this is
what i was going to do
in in february of my last year in high
school except that in those days you had
nine examinations and you had to pass
them all
or you didn't matriculate so you know
it i was really taking a a leap here
but uh and the the
examinations were written in the old
armory
on university avenue where they were
just
immediately to the west of osgood hall
it's now a
supreme court building but
there was an armory there
and several hundred of us of all ages
mainly older people
came in each day put down five dollars
and we could write the examination
and i i worked like a beaver to prepare
for those examinations and i
passed them all and
if you'll pardon me of quite a personal
recollection
uh the way my father's house worked he
stayed up late
this is a habit i got from him he stayed
up late and he slept in
i mean he he got a lot done in a day but
he's
he was operating on a slightly different
clock for most people
well in those days the post office
delivered the mail to the house at about
8 30 in the morning
and on one particular day in the spring
of 1962 my mother got and she saw this
letter from the ministry of education
addressed to me
so she surmised might be my results so
she brought it to me
i opened up and i said well it was a
scrape i had a 50 and a 51 but i passed
everything and i have matriculated and
i'm eligible for the university though i
won't get into
mcgill or toronto which is what i wanted
but i'll get into one of them
so she disappeared and
something that was unheard of in our
house at about
ten minutes to nine in the morning i
heard
the unmistakable footfall of my father
in his dressing gown as it turned out
he said i congratulate you extended his
hand that's right
and he went back to bed now it sounds
absurd but it was a very moving
experience
when he congratulated me i said well you
know
you've been more than intelligent and i
thank you for that he said
it's fine you know congratulations it
was
that means a lot and what do you what do
you what do you think motivated him to
congratulate you at that point and why
do you think it meant so much to you
i had great we had our differences in
those days not
not in later years but you know
as one does you know one does have
differences with parents sometimes
and um but i i he was a very very
intelligent man
and and a good man and i had great
respect and admiration for him and for
him to congratulate me in a way
that wasn't perfunctory it wasn't you
know
well done if you you know want to hand
it cards or something
the way he said it he imparted a
seriousness to it
that made it clear to me that he thought
that what i had done was a major
achievement and the fact that he thought
it was
not only confirmed my view that it was
in fact something an achievement
but the fact that he thought it was a
major achievement coming from a very
successful and intelligent man
which he was and who was after all the
principal
male figure in my life uh
it was it was a milestone for me and
what do you think made that
accomplishment particularly worthy of
both memory and note
what did it do for you now you have
alluded to the fact that you were
causing some trouble in in high school
yeah yeah
look in a way it legitimized the
comparative hell raising of my late high
school years
it sort of wiped the slate clean the
score at the end of the game is you win
see you graduated so you weren't just a
rebel without a cause
yeah well i maybe didn't have a cause
but at least the rebellion ended with me
still in one piece and and and in
defensible shape morally if you will i
mean in terms of the uh
the my ability to defend my conduct as a
whole not every part of it
right right yeah so you you i mean for
all the nonsense and and the
you know foolishness that and i i had my
full share of it for people that age
it ended well and it was look
it embarrassed me to say this and
particularly at this
remove in time but it actually was
simply an achievement for somebody who
hadn't been in the habit of really
concentrating that much on school work
to buckle down and study all of these
things
and and and i had some i had some good
scores i mean my overall average
was not bad and and to do it all and
pass it all the way i did
was uh it was an achievement right well
it sounds like that's when you
learn to actually do some academic work
that's right
i think i think that is i think that is
absolutely correct right and that's a
great good preparation for university
because
you do a lot better at university if you
can work on your own i mean when i went
to
especially when you when you're getting
close to the exams you have to
really swat it up you know yes yes i
mean i didn't work in high school
and i learned to work in university and
there was a big difference and it was
very much worthwhile learning to work
and
okay so you went off to university and
you have i have specific reasons to ask
you about university i've had
discussions with a number of people
recently about their university
memories some young people including yon
mi park who
is a refugee or an escapee from north
korea who just spent four years
at colombia in new york which was a
dream of hers and described it to me as
a complete waste of time and money
and when i pushed her on that insisted
that she didn't have one course or one
professor worthy of note which was
terribly shocking to me
and then i followed that up with rex
murphy who
went to memorial university in the 1950s
and late 1950s and
had nothing but positive things to say
about his experience so
and for me when i went to i went to a
small college to begin with but i had a
excellent professors there they taught
me they were admirable people they paid
a lot of attention to me and to my
friends i learned to write i learned to
work
i learned well i learned i learned how
to buckle down and
and and be serious about my academic
pursuits so for me
all the memories almost all the memories
of certainly my early university
education
and my graduate education for that
matter were positive so
but things may have changed since then
but your experience
yeah i i imagine that young lady i i
from all i hear
most of these well-known american
universities have just gone to pieces
but about
maybe the maybe the graduate departments
are better i don't know but uh
i imagine she at least enjoyed living in
new york city she'd learned something
from that and it was such a
vital city uh but the um
uh you you actually set this up for me
very nicely and put me in mind of a
couple of things
uh as an undergraduate the
uh i did encounter a professor
who who who did have a very profound
impact on my ability to focus on things
and
and my and my interest in certain
subjects uh you may even know her for
overall i know naomi griffiths she would
now be in her early 80s i think but
uh um she she's a specialist in acadian
studies she was very friendly with the
late
governor general romeo leblanc but um
she was a very fine lecturer and
and also a very kindly and
sociable person and then i got to know
her a little bit
uh and and and she she
she did help focus me in certain
historic areas but what what happened
uh after i graduated from carlton was
we were i was in 1965 and we were
we were getting into um
they sort of run up to the centennial
and the uh especially in ottawa there
was a great emphasis on uh
uh on um you know
biculturalism and and it was clear that
things were starting to
really uh simmer in unpredictable ways
in quebec unpredictable politically
and it was in the autumn of that year
that in in the guise of seeking a
majority
um mr pearson and his advisors some of
whom i got to know quite well
subsequently uh called an election and
their real motive was to bring in some
strong federalists from quebec that they
had never really replaced mr salara as
the federal
leader in quebec and um and that was
when
pierre trudeau and jean-marchand gerard
peltier and others came in
and and they were starting to sort of
pivot to meet
this challenge to federalism from quebec
and uh one thing led to another and
um because i was unsure what i wanted to
do i
for a year i operated i
bought for practically nothing because
it wasn't worth anything
from a good friend of mine who
who peter white who had lived
as my sub tint in my place in ottawa my
last year when he was working with
maurice sobe but subsequently the
concert to the governor general but he
was not a
junior minister in mr pearson's
government um
but the first of that avant-garde from
the sort of new quebec
and and he owned a little newspaper in
the eastern townships about 60 miles
east of montreal
and um in nolton quebec
and i bought a half interest not for 500
which is 499 dollars more than it was
worth commercial
but that's what i did for a while and it
and
it it and that was while you were why
while you were a student
yeah you know it was it was after i
finished as an undergraduate and before
i went on to
to my next university and and so what
happened was
that infected me with interest in the
newspaper business
i'd always had some because i was
interested in the
again the style of some of these famous
newspaper owners you know uh
like william randolph hearst for example
the most obvious example of colonel
mccormick on the chicago tribune
uh and up to a point some of the british
press owners lord beaver bureau who was
alive and
lord northcliff and some others and um
but obviously sitting out in eastern
townships producing an eight-page half
tabloid was
a long way from living in san clemente
you know mr hurst famous house in
california
but uh the um it also
infected me with the
an interest in quebec and french quebec
and um even though it was an english
paper you know
we there were you know obviously one was
in a largely french meal yeah
so the upshot of that was that
the next year i
became a law student at la valle
university french university in quebec
city
and uh and that was a terribly
interesting and positive experience i
have to say even though we were
i think only 15 english-speaking
law i mean primarily english-speaking
law students in a faculty of uh
500 or so and in the graduate arts
building where we were
tall building we were there there were
thousands of students coming and going
and
there could have been more than 50 of us
who weren't basically french speaking
and
in many cases exclusively french
speaking and
um and and it was an entirely positive
experience
there was no absolutely no
ethnic antagonism i mean people got on
well or they didn't but not for ethnic
reasons
and i have to say those people all of
them could not have been
more welcoming and pleasant as a group
and i've always been so biased
yes questions to come out of that is um
what did your undergraduate career do
for you
why were you motivated to buy this
newspaper and why did you go to a
french-speaking university for
law school ah well
the the my undergraduate career was the
point at which i
turn from being largely a social
operative effectively studying as
frankly jordan i think most
young men do as undergraduates studying
chiefly uh female anatomy and
contents of
the containers of alcoholic beverages
and and i was more successful at the
second than the first but
but but one got on you know and then you
did you studied as much as you needed to
well
the naomi griffiths helped motivate me
to treat it as a little more than
something
where you just passed the years and
checked the box of
going from first to second to graduating
year
what did she do to do that she she
gave me the vision of actually becoming
an authority on some part of history
and also writing about history then
then um so that would be my
main answer to your first question now
your your last one was
was why a french university you're
saying was why i bought the newspaper i
think
yes i i was at loose hands you say so
and and so
frankly my friend peter white said look
here i i need an editor of this paper
i'm i'm here in ottawa and and uh and
then
at the end of it the government changed
in quebec
and the union nationale won duplessi's
old party one with mr johnson daniel
johnson senior and he hired peter white
as
his chief english language assistant he
was head of the english language section
of the premier of quebec's office
which is a serious position in the in
the english community of quebec
that is that is an important position
and and he conducted it extremely well
and mr johnson was it was a was a very
impressive man i thought and still think
but um
he said look i've got to have an editor
for this paper
i'm going to close the paper why don't
you buy
a half interest phenomenal sum and be
the resident editor for a while until
you decide what to do
and then one thing led to another and he
was an alumnus of the law faculty of
laval and the number of
famous english canadians were most
famously brian mulrooney
he was he was in peter's class i mean
they're older than i am they're but
five or six years older than that and um
michael millions and other he's a
senator he's now i think the chancellor
of mcgill university his
grandfather was the prime minister and
um
and others and and so once i got into
that emilia
i because of who i knew i i got a little
bit into the edges of
quebec politics and i met premier
johnson and
our paper served the english residence
of the vice premier of quebec and the
subsequent premier jean-jacques
that period coming up to 1967
with the fermentation in quebec which
was
very active politically but not nothing
violent about it at that point
um uh it it it was an exciting
atmosphere
and uh and and you also said that you
had become aware of newspaper owners
approximately at this point and and so
well it just the way they lived it was i
mean
look i'd never have aspired to live in
the in the
oriental monarchical faction fashion of
william randall first
made most famous and caricatured and
citizen kane uh you know which
orson welles officially denied anything
to do with hers but
as time magazine put it lawyers for mr
william
randall first have determined otherwise
and to prosecute it accordingly
but the um uh the
uh it it developed along that way so i i
became motivated academically then
had a reason to move to quebec and get
involved in this
most modest scale you can be short of
just being a newspaper delivery boy
but in a position where i did everything
i was the publisher and the editor
man i hadn't an assistant who did the
actual clerical work but
you know i sold the ads i produced the
circulation campaign such as they were
and i wrote most of the content
so
yeah and then and then and then i
thought it would be a good idea to
pursue my studies
in quebec in a french university and and
uh
peter white helped me and uh indeed um
the premier allowed his name to stand as
as a recommendation now
in quebec city in 1966 if someone
appeals for it
or applies for entry to the law faculty
and and one of the sponsors is the prime
minister of quebec
i mean unless it's a joke and this guy
has never got past grade seven
he's going to be admitted and and and um
and and it was a an entirely positive
experience but
it you must understand it was a double
and ultimately a triple experience if i
may
elaborate i really had to learn the
language i knew
kind of basic french high school
graduate in ontario knows where i would
know a few words but i didn't really
know how to put a serious sentence
together
or speak fluently and at that age my
early 20s you know i wanted
you know i wanted a social life i didn't
want to live like a monk you know and
so i you know you really have to pick it
up and
and so i was learning the language and
also
it came up that in 1969 when i was
into my final year in law school
the sherbrooke daily wreck and they were
into a daily newspaper here albeit
small and eight or nine thousand
circulation came up for sale
on a distressed basis because they they
over committed to buying a press
thinking they could sell enough
business on the press to pay for it and
they didn't so they were
they were restrained and so peter white
and a
third friend of ours and i bought that
paper so in that
space of time i became you know i i
made a major advance my academic career
qualified myself
uh as a law graduate
we picked up if i may say a pretty good
solid competence in french and
became a newspaper co-owner i believe i
was the only
publisher of a daily newspaper certainly
the only
one i've ever heard of anywhere who was
at the same time a lawsuit
now there may have been others but i
haven't heard of anything like that and
and so that that
it was really out of that brief period
the rest of earth much of the balance of
my career was launched
you know that you know that that happens
to everybody i suppose but it was a
slightly different pattern for me than
most
why law yeah i look
it's uh it's the neutral place it was
not that i ever
particularly desired to be a lawyer but
you never go wrong with it you know it
always helps you as the qualification
for whatever
you're going to do and parts of it are
an interesting subject now i focused on
uh constitutional and international
uh and um you know if you haven't helped
anyone relying on my recollections of
the
quebec civil code to get them through a
you know a median wall case or some one
of you these
funny minor bits of litigation you get
but but uh
but you know the law is a broad field
there's lots of stuff that's interesting
you know
i i never particularly desired to
practice i never did practice
i had a couple of minimum wage cases
where our campaign was the defendant
and i got i got brian mulroney he was a
labor lawyer to coach me a bit and
i did exactly what he told me to and we
won the two cases about i was you know
that's the only practice
i've ever had i will say that it's been
very useful to me i mean
unfortunately you know i've had a great
deal of legal experience as a
as a a client of lawyers including some
very famous lawyers in the united states
and britain and canada
but but uh and and that that that does
help you if you if you know something
about it
the the basis of the law it does help
you in dealing with fires
so how did you manage your your career
as a publisher and your studies at that
point
well i was a pretty much of an absentee
publisher uh
i i would come there when i could and do
certain things i called upon certain
advertisers
in montreal and toronto when i when i
was able to
uh but but you know that was in
uh that was uh about nine months before
i graduated after that i was a resident
publisher and then we started to build
the business and branched out and
bought more papers and it grew and grew
so the first paper
that you bought you did you did you said
the bulk of the writing and so how much
time were you spending writing
in a week at that point oh
when when i was the resident uh
publisher of a weekly paper
yep uh it took
probably eight or ten hours to write the
main contents of the paper so
for each week i mean you know yeah it's
not it's not
absolutely the uh you know the
chronicles of uh you know it's not the
best collected editorials of the london
times no but you have to commit to
producing
yeah you gotta you gotta get it to paper
yes i mean people are often curious
about what it takes to be a writer and i
mean one of the things that it takes to
be a writer is to write
and and to produce constantly and on a
schedule
at least that's how it seems to me and
it appears that that
you had it you had a deadline that was
continually renewing itself and
you had to produce content come hell or
high water fundamentally
yeah and what you've said is very
perceptive is now
i i i mean you there's no reason why you
would know this but
i have millions of readers in the united
states i write these columns and not
four of them
every week in the us and it's just what
you said it's a deadline that comes up
all of that
now you know it's only uh 1200
uh words so it's not you know it's not
that much writing but on the other hand
you know it it it's a highly competitive
field and you don't
no one's going to pay you if no one
reads you so you have to put down
something yeah well and that's still 365
000 words
no not a year you said weekly yeah yeah
right so it's 100 000 words a year it's
a book a year
yeah right yeah this is true and uh no
no you know the news cycle is what it is
there's always plenty to write a bit but
um
uh but that got me into that habit
you're absolutely right where you're
writing your deadline
and you can't bark at the deadline if i
if i could make a detour here but a
relevant one as
as you know and many of your viewers
would uh i was
for a time a guest of the people of the
united states and the bureau of prisons
now
i ultimately won that battle i won it
entirely and in addition
ultimately the charges were
retroactively withdrawn
but and it was it was an outrage from a
to zed but
but my what i did while i was there
was i was a tutor to
students who did not succeed in the
program the us bureau of prisons has
of requiring everyone who has not
graduated from
secondary school to do so and so they
have
teachers and examinations every month
and those who were unsuccessful they
would send to me
and i recruited other tutors i recruited
a
a former um head of the torpedo room of
a nuclear submarines my sciences
tutor because i'm not qualified to do
that and for mathematics the
head of mathematics former head of
mathematics of a
large high school in little rock
arkansas was also a successful
commodities trader
and these were people that were
imprisoned at the same time yes
yeah but you know the
non-violent things i think one was a tax
case the other was a
alleged fraudulent use of a credit card
or something but they
but they're highly qualified people so
the three of us were
were tutoring these people and and um
and
these people would be sent to us and
they would arrive very
kind of selling and suspicious which the
conduct of the
american criminal legal system who
invites and
incites and then largely justifies
um and i would give them a little speech
that they didn't have to do a thing if
they didn't want to
but if they wanted to leave there with
their foot on
the up escalator and an excellent chance
to make
a good living in a way that didn't lead
straight back to a place like this i
could help
them if they didn't want that that was
fine i didn't care but i was there
if they wanted but the one thing i
didn't want was for them to imagine that
i was part of this awful system
i was a bigger victim of it than they
probably were because i didn't commit
any offenses
with that the whole thing turned and
they became fully cooperative and it was
so why did that
be okay why did you formulate that
speech why did you think it was
justifiable and why did it have a
positive effect on
on the people that you were discussing
because they had
in that great rich country of the united
states and i'm not a socialist but they
had not had a fair deal
most of them scarcely had any idea who
their father was and
and and and from early times their
mother or somebody was saying somebody's
got to get some money here we're going
to be
in the street and uh and they were just
cannon fodder in the drug war i mean
they were at the last edge they were
the last stage of transfer so some
draghi was picked up they say
where'd you get that from and they'd
finger that person and
you know and then and you know they were
they were cooked
so off they went to prison terribly
overseas one of my students
got 25 years for driving a truck
loaded with marijuana he wasn't even a
user himself anyway
you know a lot of 23 or something by the
way i am
one thing i am proud of in in
in that same sense is the my initial uh
graduation from high school myself was
that all of my lads passed
206 and some of them had to take exams
more than once
but they all graduate how long were you
how long were you imprisoned in doing
this
uh three years and two weeks how long
did it take after you were in prison
before you started
doing this tutoring and why did you do
it no i i mean it was
how how long after i arrived in prison
did it start yeah only about a month
because one of my books was in the
library and the head of education said
look here we we've got to do something
with these guys who just keep
failing i mean there's nothing wrong
with their iq but
let's try something different instead of
our teachers would you do it and
and then i would and to answer your
question about why i gave them a little
speech so-called it was hardly a speech
but it was i pretty much
said to you what i said to them
it was because i i knew that they
initially would think i was part of this
evil system
that they hated and i had to make them
understand that
i was one of them and not one of the
others you see and that wasn't a
pretense it wasn't a
uh a falsehood i was i mean my heart was
with the prisoners and not with the but
you were also selling them something you
were selling them literacy as an escape
from their
current conditions selling themselves
interest
and as you know that that's that's
that's as the australians say
it's a trier yeah i mean that's one
that'll go you know and
and um but what i was going to say
about them was and this is going back to
what you're saying about meeting
deadlines
the american or at least the florida
matriculation system
that's that's where it was um
required an essay and so
i said all right you know
write an essay and they had various
topics that were usually used so i said
take your pick of these
and some of some of these fellows
literally couldn't write a word they had
a mental block they couldn't write a
word
and the way i got around that was i said
look
we'll change the subject here you write
on the sexiest woman
you've ever seen and you can use your
imagination there doesn't have to be
such a woman you can just
make her up and you and only i will read
this
so if it'll help you be
as coarse and vulgar
as you want use any sexual word you want
any way you want
anything just write what comes to mind
and uh
and that got them all going none of them
had a had a
a mental block after that why in the
world did you
take that tack and what made them why in
the world did they trust you
and then i have another question too
which is why did they pass
why were you successful when the when
the other teachers let's say or the
system that was hypothetically designed
to educate them failed
well because they wouldn't put out for
them they thought it was another
trick of the you know the establishment
to
to use them and they in in their minds
they were obliged to provide them food
and shelter
and uh and as long as they
we just sort of sullenly went along with
things they didn't harass them too much
and that so that was minimum compliance
but it was a survival
regime for them and that was really
where their lives were reduced to at
that point
and so i i produced a sort of spark of
light
that they could actually better their
lot
raise their higher ability and therefore
they're legitimate
by which i mean legal uh
income aspiration because they
matriculated from high school they were
more hireable than if they hadn't been
and
indeed in the case of a number of them i
i assisted them in becoming
correspondence students in universities
and and indeed i had a a couple of them
who started there then were released and
continued
physically at the university and
graduated i'd won a couple years ago
wrote me when he
graduated from the university of alabama
a couple of years ago when i was about
six years ago but
he graduated from the university of
alabama and and uh
i to the extent i'm in touch with these
people are all doing fine they're all
well launched doing fine well this is
this is you obviously take pleasure in
this particular accomplishment
you see it was ironic uh jordan because
i didn't
i mean you know i had a few teachers i
liked we all remember the teachers we
liked but there weren't that many of
them in my case
and most of them i didn't like i i
bought into the
into the view that really they were
teachers because
they couldn't make it in the world of
adults so they
sought success in a place where they
could assert their authority over
smaller people
and i mean this was my concept of the
motivation
some of the teachers i had but um and
you know
shaw's famous comment he who can does
he who cannot teach us i sort of
believed that i thought they were
you know there were exceptions but in
general i thought
these teachers were people who couldn't
make it in a more
substantial occupation now that was an
unfair judgment but
but but on the other hand when i see
what
what level of education those who depart
our schools
uh achieve nowadays i'm not so sure it
was an unjust judgment but
any case that's what i thought but i saw
the other
side of it when i was tutoring these
guys
in in the prison system you i saw the
satisfaction of it
and i will give the bureau of prisons
this they devised this
graduation ceremony and all the families
would come
and they were emotional occasions and i
i'm not a particularly emotional person
but but
one of the few seriously emotional
positive emotional
moments i've had was when my two
colleagues and i were introduced
and and this whole packed room stood up
and cheered for about five minutes
and you know the the the girlfriends or
wives or
parents or whatever of my students would
meet my wife in the in the visiting
center and say oh
your husband is you know my guy's a
teacher and we're so grateful to even
all this stuff it was it was very
touching
and incidentally um jordan
princeton isn't the place for those
people i was in a low security place sir
none of these guys were violent and they
they weren't habitual offenders
it wasn't the right place for them
that's not the way we should treat these
people
well they're not bad people and they're
not unintelligent and as i say every one
of mine passed the problem was
they just got a wrong turning early on
so let's return to the to the newspaper
business so
now you're out of law school and you you
have a second newspaper
and you you're you've graduated now
you've taken on the role as a publisher
your empire starts to expand at that
point it does but i
i had one more uh one more
lap to run on the educational side i
became a
master's candidate and uh and did
receive the degree from mcgill
in french canada studies now this this
came
from i mean not that you've asked me i'm
volunteering it
that um i went i i
because i knew premier johnson a bit it
i i don't know how conversant you are
with modern quebec history but he was
often referred to as the sun duplicity
never had
mauricio plessy as you probably know was
the he's the only person
in history to serve five terms his
premiere of quebec and he died in office
and and dejean lasage told me that if
he'd lived he would have been re-elected
he was
he really knew how to you know how to
organize that province politically uh
and um
but he was a bachelor and but he
advanced johnson quite quickly and
johnson was
kind of his protege and and uh
he had the same speaking style very
witty way of talking
and um
would he inspired my interest in due
plessy because up until then i had the
i was the conventional english canadian
the dupless he was really
a a retrograde political character
and a scoundrel uh i mean a colorful man
and a clever man no doubt but a cynic
and
essentially much too authoritarian um
i mean there's some truth now but he the
fact is he
produced the modernization of quebec he
built the auto routes he built the
schools
he built every university except mcgill
i mean he was re-elected
because he delivered for the province
and um
but his technique was to get the
nationalists and the conservatives to
vote together which is
very difficult to do either you're too
nationalistic and frighten the
conservatives
which happened to him in 1939 or or
you're not
nationalistic enough and and and they
get impatient with you which is
what happened to jean bertrand 1970
i mean dupless he had it all organized
for paul sovie to follow him and daniel
johnson to follow him but
dupless he was a strong man who was
almost 70 when he died in office those
two died in office in the early 50s
so and then the whole thing broke up but
my point was that
uh johnson
stirred my curiosity about duplexi
because there clearly was a story to
this man that wasn't being told
he was reviled as the author of the
great darkness and all this sort of
thing
so i went to a colleague
uh happened to get an invitation and it
came from
miss griffiths who i mentioned it was my
old professor carlton
who said you might be interested in that
so i went to it in three rivers
and it was a discussion of people and
and and there was a panel there was one
pro duplessy panelist two
anti-depressant ones
and i went up to the pro duplessy one at
the end of it it was like
somewhat well-known historian roberto
rooney a frenchman originally who
who was a member of axion francaise you
know charlemagne
and he was at a demonstration in the
place de la republique in 1926
and the person next to him was shot dead
and with that he left
france and never returned immigrated to
go back anyway
he um i congratulated him on upholding
duplessa
and we conversed for a while and and
then i gave him a ride back to montreal
and uh and
it turned out that he had been
commissioned by
an outfit called in french the society
of friends of the honorable maurice du
plessis
to write a book about duplessite and and
they had all duplici's papers and
so i i the ideas came to my mind well
look
you're writing in french would they have
any interest in allowing an
english-speaking person
to look at them and and write about that
and he said well it's worth the try sure
i'll recommend you you say and and and
then it happened the head of this outfit
was the former minister of cultural
affairs
in johnson and bertrand's government
genre well tremblay you
may remember and he's still alive he's
very elderly
uh and and and and so he said yeah well
that's fine sure you can you will
you but you know you've got to keep them
to yourself and stuff all of which i
the rules i respected and so i had all
this stuff and then when i saw what i
had
i realized i had to do something about
it and this is what
takes me back to having developed at
least the ambition to write some history
so i calculated that if i enrolled at
mcgill
citing this as my proposed thesis topic
that would get me halfway through and if
i got halfway through i'd have the
momentum to finish it and
that's where my first book came from
which
which is called uh render unto caesar
the life of maurice du plessis
and uh and um so so i i got
that side of things going at the same
time as we built our newspaper company
and we bought within a few months a
daily newspaper in prince edward island
and one in prince rupert british
columbia so i could say with a
semi-straight face we have a newspaper
chain that spans the country from ocean
to ocean
but i suppose you know the links are
rather
rather wide and not many of them
so you're writing you're done your law
degree you're writing now
as well and you've got three newspapers
at this point
well then there was some weeklies we
were up to probably as many as 10 but
then we we had some weaklings around
quebec and
then we got we see there were some
available ones in british columbia
dailies and weekly so
we built it up it was still a small
company compared to you know the ones
that own the big newspapers in the
country but
we built it up to something a bit of
scale and stature fairly quickly
but but it was a it's a it was a very
profitable business
and normally we would um
make a bid based on the profitability of
the present owner
and and very rarely were these people
who owned the papers
running them as profitably as they could
they were taking a nice salary for
themselves and they weren't that
concerned with what the profit was
well we had an idea of what we could do
with the profit and
and then and then in those days you
could go to the local bank
and say uh look we you know we want to
buy this paper
and uh we want we we're asking you to
loan us half the money we'll take care
of the rest
what we do is we give the vendor a
balance of sale notice so we didn't put
up any
not a cent and but but we always did
raise the profit we always raised the
quality of the product too and our
position always was
that the best way to raise the profit
was to raise the
the quality of the product and even then
people who bought and read a newspaper
were what is called abs
abc1 readers either high income
or high education relatively speaking i
mean ignorant people didn't
buy newspapers and and and
for the most part poor people didn't buy
newspapers and people advertisers
wouldn't be interested in wouldn't buy a
newspaper but anyone who bought a
newspaper or someone
an advertiser wants to get to because he
has disposable income
how much was your ability to make these
newspapers that you purchased profitable
and also to see an opportunity there a
consequence of
you having done everything when you
bought your first newspaper
uh considerable because i i knew how
much manpower you needed
and and almost all was these places had
more manpower than they needed now you
know we handled
gently you know we moved them out you
know
basically a lot of them were elderly so
we just gave them early retirement
topped up their pensions a bit and
things like that but but um
and they're small so you're not talking
about a lot of people but if you
if you've got a newspaper of 50
employees
and you get eight of them to take early
retirement
you've got the payroll by almost 20 and
and um
and it's not that early retirement you
know and
in addition to that are all kinds of
things to do to enhance revenue
i mean very few of them had any notion
of how you
you know how you can hype the
circulation
relatively easily with contests and
things like that
i i was astounded at the people and
where we really saw this was in england
or the daily telegraph with daily
circulation over a million broadchief
papers the
biggest broadsheet paper in europe
the british love these as far as i'm
concerned actually ridiculous contests
but
if you give them a contest even to get a
you know a
free subscription to the spectator which
we also own
they'll plunge into it it's a
circulation building
so that's the sort of thing that a you
know an individual sitting in for
argument's sake nelson british columbia
having owned this newspaper for 30 years
he wouldn't know that it wouldn't matter
he lived well he was an influential
person in his community made a profit
every year having taken a nice salary
for himself has three or four relatives
in the payroll
you know the the company owns his car
and there's his
speed boat in the lake and all this kind
of stuff i mean to him that's all he
needs
which is fine but the fact is you can
double the profits quite quickly
so now do you have a plan at this point
you're you're being successful in
purchasing newspapers and increasing
their profitability so you're building
up more capital
are you are you planning do you have an
aim at this point just to continue
expanding and do you have an interest
and we and we brought it a long way
forward the biggest
uh the biggest paper we had
when things changed because of that
shake-up in the ravel system argus thing
that you mentioned in your intro
where when i started to focus on finance
um was la soleil
quebec city which sir wilfrid laurier
was once the chairman
that was a newspaper about 120 000
circulation a day
it's not big for toronto but it's so
that's that's what is that it's uh
you know i'm trying to say i i don't
know the newspaper circulations now i've
been out of the business for a long time
but
you know that's 120 000 papers today
it's a respectable size paper it's not a
huge newspaper but it's not it's not
like the northern eastern townships
advertiser
and there was some history to the slay
as well so
well-known paper and quebec
so you by the way the the the history
part that i best use from my studies of
duplessy
where the you know it was as i said sir
wilfred was the chairman at one time was
an
absolute died in the wool liberal
newspaper but
uh the the owner jacques
nicole and he owned the newspapers in
three rivers
and sherbrooke uh also
um he he was one of the few people who
was a senator
and a legislative counselor but the
opera house of quebec in those days used
both at the same time
and and he was the liberal party
chairman for 20 years provincially while
they were in office just before dublin
and for nearly 20 years after when they
were in office in ottawa
he was a very powerful man in quebec and
in the early days of television
he he got the license douglas through
his political contacts for
eastern quebec southeastern quebec
around sherbrooke and the best place to
put his transmitter was at the top of
mount orford which was a provincial park
so he asked duplessy if he could put his
his you know his transmitter there and
to bless he said
uh you know jacob you can you can put it
there and you don't have to
pay me more than one dollar rent for me
being the province of the bank
but not as long as
right under the words le soleil on your
leading newspaper are the words
the liberal orga he said right at that
point
leslie never mind that mr nicole was a
liberal senator and legislative
counselor became a union national
newspaper
he just switched like that and he got
his license anyway that that
but that's a in a way a red bearing but
i thought i thought it might amuse your
viewers a bit all right so you're
building up a newspaper empire
it's it's it it's in canada it's limited
to canada at this point but you start to
expand
is it first in the us or first in the uk
and how does that but
we started to move in the u.s in um
let me think now we got going there in
about
uh 70
75 we bought a paper just over the
border in vermont
and then and then and then at gradeway i
mean of course in a market that size
we fairly rapidly bought a huge number
of these small papers we had a formula
to
operate them and and you could bundle
them together by region
and then when you when you combined
their circulation they became
quite substantial in circulation if you
had enough of them and and as you said
in your intro we had hundreds of these
papers
and were you run were you running
writers across the papers or were
these all in in in independent fiefdoms
there were a few that we that we could
we could run or or buy from the outside
at a discount
for ourselves rather than the unit cost
that the
obtained if we were only buying for one
little paper ten thousand sale or
something like that
so we got economies to scale to a degree
but in the papers like that you
you absolutely have to serve the local
public and and
you're relatively speaking not under
threat from television
let alone once it came the internet as
much in this local paper
because you know cbs or the cbc or
whatever you want
are not going to carry the you know the
the strawberry festival of the town your
papers publishing you know they just
have
the room for it so you're giving people
what they can't get anywhere else
and is that still the case are are the
smaller communities
the internet has become so pervasive now
i think it's a threat even to those
papers but
but not as not as much as it is to a
metropolitan paper
so how are you managing your time at
this point you have you have an
increasingly large
media empire you're also still right
about
into into regions and i had the east and
associates had the west and then then
the
big turn came in the matter you referred
to when the uh
you know when the what was called at the
time the argus group accompanies the
control
that became available and now that that
was quite an intricate business because
the
number of voting chairs involved was
quite small
so you you because my father had his
position he died in 1976
so my brother and i we technically we
didn't inherit his talk we bought it
from his
state but but in effect with meredith
and um
and and then there was a shareholders
agreement and
uh the the principal associate died and
there was some jockeying around in any
case we
in accordance with the shareholders
agreement we bought the other stocks so
we had we had control
of the voting shares which had uh
of this company which had influential
blocks of stock and historically
controlling blocks of stock although
for in most cases they weren't a
majority of the shares
of a number of famous companies massey
ferguson was one of the farm equipment
banker
dominion stores the grocery stores
domtar the forestry products company
and um uh the most interesting in a way
was the
old hollinger mining company it didn't
do much mining but
it owned 60 of an outfit that that own
big iron ore positions in in labrador in
northern quebec
and long-term contracts to ship the ore
that produced about
40 million dollars of royalties every
year basically no cost
the steel companies and their
affiliates in the united states took the
aura and paid us the royalties so we had
that cash to work with
and then and then what i did was over a
period i reoriented
that flow of cash and that business into
the newspaper business
and we really really took off when
when i i bought control of the london
daily telegraph which was in a
distressed financial state
for 30 million dollars which we
ultimately sold for
1.327 billion dollars
how much how how long a period of time
elapsed between the purchase and the
sale
from uh 1986
to 2004.
18 years yeah well that's quite the
return on investment so are you in
england
you buy the telegraph are you spending
much of your time in britain at that
point
well after we bought it i i went there
for two years in the summers only and
then i
made and then i made it my chief
residence after that for
uh about 15 years yeah so what was it
like
moving from toronto to britain
well i i kept my home in my office here
but in the sense you mean it i mean yes
i moved my main residence well look it
it it
moving into britain as an owner of a big
newspaper
is not like just you know getting off
the plane at heathrow and
going through the waterheads to find a
job for yourself you know so i i was
rather well received because of the
position i had
uh but it was very interesting it's a
it's a
i was fortunate to get the very
tail end of that era when newspaper
owners were very influential people
i mean i i don't think they are
particularly influential now but and
it's not
it's not a good business now but um uh
it it it you know london is one of the
world's greatest cities and
if if you're well situated in london
you meet a tremendous variety of
interesting people who are either live
there or come through there virtually
everybody you can think of comes through
london at some point in a year
and and you know there's normally some
sort of
occasion for them so my wife and i were
constantly receiving these formidable
sort of
stiff gold-aged invitations to
come to have dinner with so-and-so or
lunch with so-and-so or something
and uh it you know it was a sumptuous
life
but but um but i mean my interest in it
was really
in the socializing with people as well
as at that time
i was a supporter of mrs thatcher and
and
it was a very interesting and active
time politically in britain as she
effectively de-socialized the country
how well did you know her
i got to know her very well she was my
sponsor
in the house of lords and and and she
and dennis came to our wedding party and
they often came to dinner with us
so you you went you went to
you lived in britain after you were in
canada how
it'd be interesting for me to hear how
you would contrast the cultures
what was it like being in britain i mean
i know you were in a
in a very fortunate position when you
moved there and so you you
entered in the upper echelons of society
but you had a chance to see
britain from the inside and to contrast
it with canada and with the us to some
degree
so so what did you observe and what did
you conclude
uh well it was a country being renewed
you know i mean
britain at the time that
thatcher was elected very narrowly
elected in 1979
was a country with tight currency
controls uh
top personal tax rate of 98 percent so
there's a lot of tax cheating going on
and the british don't like that you know
i mean
the real problem with britain and europe
was not immigration it was it it was the
authoritarianism of directives from
brussels
uh and and you know the the the french
and the italians essentially ignore the
government as much as they can
anyway and they don't care what these
directives are they're not going to pay
much attention to them
unless they absolutely have to and the
french in particular are not going to
take seriously anything that comes from
the belgians
and or at least from within belgium and
and the germans are the leading power in
europe and they're accustomed to
regimentation so it doesn't bother them
but the british like to be law abiding
they like to obey the law
but but they have to be sensible laws
and they have to be
uh imposed by people that are
accountable so if you don't like what
they're doing you can throw them out at
the
you know the voting guys and and that
was the problem well
that in addition to the economic
stagnation finally
finally you know boiled over when
thatcher and her friends
keith joseph and and others pushed out
ted heath for edward heath and and took
the conservative party of great britain
conservative and unionist party to
to the right not the extreme right but
to a level of conservatism that
conservative fiscal policy and tax
policy in particular
and attitude to to labor unions that
that the conservative party had not
occupied
really since uh the early days of
stanley baldwin
and uh and and it wasn't back to them
but it was ideologically a similar
position but obviously refined to
reflect
changes in society uh over that
period of more than 50 years and so it
was very interesting to see and she was
successful i mean
i i was there for her
third election victory she was the first
prime minister since before the first
reform act
in the early 1830s to win three
consecutive full terms majority terms
as prime minister and and she did it on
the basis of radical change to the
country
and it was quite exciting now at that
time
i was that was in the late 80s uh
uh you know brian mulreney was an old
friend of mine
uh he he was he was
i mean your question didn't deal with
politics only but that
given my position as a news in newspaper
business politics had a lot to do with
this
um and brian was doing something about
but canada as old was
operated you know much closer to the
middle of the field
uh you know it never got that far left
and and and he didn't
move it as far as thatcher moved britain
and in any case that
you know it's not a unitary state like
britain it's a much different system but
the
the um
if you didn't have i mean i thought
brian was a good prime minister but you
didn't have that
sense of profound change and radical
change and
exciting policy formulation i mean it
was one of the few periods in my life
where i
uh sort of transmogrified into a into a
sort of semi
policy wong because we had positions and
all this stuff
and the other aspect that was the the
cold war was still going on
and there was still some controversy in
britain in that there
there was always in the left wing of the
labor party especially and
and the far out old imperialist wing of
the tories as well
this this antagonism to the united
states
and um uh when i moved there it was in
the latter reagan years and of course he
was an
important president and and had an
eventful
period as president and uh and then i it
happened i need him too
i'd known him before he was president
and um
so i i i you know i wasn't under the
illusion that i was at the center of
things i wasn't but i was
i was actually pretty close to the
center in britain
because my first trip
there is the chief shareholder of the
telegraph company the prime minister
invited me
to lunch on saturday at checkers
and uh she said look here you know we
need you
and we can't win without you are you
with us
with you and and i said but let me ask
you something
and this was right after mr murdock had
uh uh you know had had made his big
changeover
and moved to a new plant and
de-certified and basically dismissed
the old uh you know the
the old pre-print and printing unions
that used to shut the papers down all
the time arbitrarily and the
shop foreman would have you know lose a
game of darts at his pub or something
and come in and call all the workers out
it was almost as bad as that
and and and she since
murdoch was acting within the law she
ensured
that his titles could be produced i said
look i don't think we're going to
get to the point that rupert's at or but
you know we're putting through uh
voluntary retirements but you don't know
and
if we need to import people from
other countries to help get our papers
out she interrupted me and said i'll
sign the work permits myself
and uh that was it as charles powell her
long-serving chief secretary very
distinguished public servant in britain
wrote uh politically speaking it was
love at first sight i mean he was there
that luncheon
and we just got on like smoke and did
right to the day she died
well she was a little non-com
non-compass mental slatterly but
uh you know she would i knew her well i
knew her very well
and as i said at our barbers and my
wedding party i
thanked her and said if you know
i never would have come to this country
or wish to do business in this country
if it wasn't for you and that was true
so what what made her able to do what
she did i mean
she was a woman in a sea of men she was
a radical leader in many ways obviously
on the conservative
front she had apparently had tremendous
strength of character like what did you
see in her that made her able to do what
she did
she was an extremely courageous person
and she was that
type of person who focused
exclusively on relevant
sequential facts in analyzing a problem
and and she you know she had been a i
believe the education secretary in the
heath government
70-74 and and
and was the co-founder of the center for
policy studies she came to the
conclusion along with a number of others
some of them were intellectually more
frankly sophisticated than she was like
keith joseph
uh that that britain simply had to
change that what was called the aptly
settlement
where where it it it was colloquially in
britain called butscalism after rabb
butler
uh and hugh gatesco who was gatesville
was the leader of labour party between
clement atlee and harold wilson and
and rav butler was the deputy prime
minister
for and and all was the runner-up the
leader all through the
churchill eden macmillan years in the
into the heath period
and and and and uh uh uh sir alec that
was cheating also
and it's it was it was kind of a
lookalike government show where they
agreed in those things and that
margaret concluded this isn't working
britain is
falling behind our standard of living
is is not keeping pace with the germans
or the french or the americans
and um and and this is why and we've got
to change
and she was absolutely right but you
know sometimes
just stating home truths in simple ways
is so far from what people are used to
it sounds more radical than it is what
she was saying
wasn't in fact all that radical she was
saying things like
we can't have just completely
irresponsible work stoppages
we can't have capricious middle level
union officials just calling everybody
out
for the fun of it whenever they you know
had a bad night or something
and and and and we can't take 98 of
people's income and it's nonsense i mean
it's just nonsense
it'll it'll cost 99 cents to collect the
98 cents
i mean your collection costs get too
high cheating becomes outrageous rich
people move away
it's just nonsense and um
and she had a way of putting it very
clearly and very persuasive and and
that group was was an ideal
team for that time she had she had some
people nigel lawson for example was a
former editor of the spectator uh senior
writer for the
financial times uh academic economist
but but a fine debater and and he could
he he put through absolutely
radical budgets where you know they
cut the top tax rate between jeffrey
howe and nigel they cut it
from 98 to 40 percent and
and and and you know she had
she had a group that could argue it in
parliament and
in the country she had an academic group
led by keith joseph and her center for
policy studies
crew kenneth minogue i don't know if you
know these people
well-known academic economists and
specialists in other areas
who could put it forward in a way that
was where they could defend it against
you know the best debaters of the left
and she was a powerful leader who kept
the whip on the backs of the tory party
and said this is what must be done
and this is why we have to do it and and
uh
you know when she said the ladies not
for turning and
sacked after government and so forth uh
she showed i mean she was right but but
but there's no doubt that at times
traditional opinion within that party
and the tory grandees didn't approve of
her and they never liked her and they
stabbed her in the back in the end
but even those who were involved in that
had to admit that she made a tremendous
difference
and the best of them for example michael
hasselton very able man
i'm a very good defense secretary and
then came back in other roles
but uh he uh
he agreed with her policy he couldn't
stand her person and she couldn't stand
him
but but he but he he was he was no
slacker when it came to the to the
policy she was
she was the right person for the right
time now unfortunately
um as so often happens when when
people in democratic countries have held
a
an elected office for for a while she
started to lose her sense of political
self-reservation
uh and i i you know i i became because
we had
a big parliamentary contingent in the in
the press gallery and
did a lot of political reporting and
neil kinnick the leader of the
opposition
labor leader told me one day that the
first parliamentary
report he read every morning was ours
because even though we were
rabidly pro-thatcher paper the reporting
was always fair
and all was perceptive and that was our
standard and that was what i always
tried to enforce everywhere in every
country
in all our papers was to separate
reporting and comment which you rarely
get nowadays
and um as the agitation with thatcher's
authoritarianism within the
conservative parliamentary party
increased we
we would hear it naturally and the
editors would tell me these things so i
said all right look
put ten more people into the press
conference you know they give a press
pass to anyone
that the telegraph asked for given our
position and
i mean you know we were the backbone of
the nation you know we had over a
million
sale and 98 of them are conservative
voters
and
and i said for once i will i will ignore
your
expense accounts which were outrageous
they always are from journalists and i
almost sacked the editor when
when he expected me to pay for
chartering a helicopter to take him to
drinks party in brighton
but i said look you know i'll i'll
ignore all
of that tell these guys divide it up
take the entire
conservative parliamentary party every
mp and
divide them up into groups and over the
next few months have your guys take them
all out and apply them with drink and
find out what is really going on there
and when i had all this i
asked for an appointment the prime
minister's office said to
come over later that day and and and i
said look
this is what i've done i did i've
decided name anyone that would be
dishonorable i did not
give one name but for example the chief
whip
wrentham his name was we couldn't wait
to see the back of thatcher and i don't
think you see that
you're having a clue of this so i didn't
mention him i didn't mention anybody i
said
i'm telling you prime minister
your parliamentary party is seething
with this content
there's an absolute rancid element there
and it's very
it's it's gone a long way into that
group and you've gotta
if you pardon my being so uh imperious
here
uh if you you you've got to i'm not
saying you should accommodate or appease
them but
make a few course corrections that
you know that attract more of them and
turn break the momentum of this
and um i should have brought the show
absolutely she said they're all slackers
they're cowards
i said of course they're cowards that's
what makes them dangerous
and and and you know and it was only a
few weeks later that the you know she uh
pushed poor old jeffrey howe out and uh
uh
and the 1922 society the group of
non-cabinet mps in the governing party
essentially gave her the high jump and
and um
it was it was it was very unfortunate in
the um
and we ran an editorial on
on the uh on the front page was very
rare
the day before and then which i
contributed the last sentence
the editor max hastings was not a pro
thatcher person but the last sentence
was
that um margaret thatcher is one of the
great leaders who has arisen in a
thousand years of british history
and as long as she wishes to remain as
prime minister she may count on the
support of this newspaper
and she wrote the handwritten personal
letter thanking me
uh but but she went and uh
i i told the
editor to put a black border around the
story and he said
please you're not serious are you so i i
spared it in that but
that's how i felt it was it was it was a
tragedy
not a tragedy but a sadness she was a
great leader but you know
jordan i don't believe in term limits i
mean basically the voters will decide
and if they've got a good person in
office let let's
keep the person there and in the united
states the only time in the history of
that country
where anyone saw the third term the
entire future of our civilization
depended
on his being elected and that was
franklin d roosevelt in 1940
because the republicans would never have
come up with lynd lease and britain and
canada could not have continued in the
war
um and they wouldn't have got a war
leader as good as that anyway wendell
wilkie was a good man but he was no fdr
but uh if we look back at it
in in in the last what
50 or 60 years the only leaders in
uh you know in important countries
who've left
office in good physical health and good
political health
were the term limited americans
eisenhower and reagan
and maybe clinton but more eisenhower
and reagan
i mean if if they'd been allowed to and
had chosen to do it either
would have won a third term easily
they're very popular but
but you know you as roosevelt said
you've got to have a new
even though it's you running for
reelection has to be for a new reason
you have to give the people a new reason
to vote for
which he did do i mean he was you know
beat the depression uh you know
accelerate prosperity stay out of war
win the war you know in a different in a
different thing each time
but um i i digress now
margaret thatcher was she she was very
courageous
and very admirable i i have to and and
also a wonderful person
in small ways i mean the staff that
downing street and checkers loved her
she was terribly polite to these people
in a way that
uh you know and some of some of the
labor prime ministers like callahan
weren't particularly
um and and certainly a man like ted
heath had no manners anyway so he wasn't
polite to anyone
it was a i mean i rather liked him as a
person and he was an interesting man in
a way i didn't particularly like him
politically
but but he wasn't very polite and but
margaret thatcher was very polite to
those people no matter how rough she was
in her own ministers she felt they could
defend themselves
but you know someone serving tea at
downing street was
couldn't and so you had to be polite to
these people and she was never
condescending about it i mean
she was from grantham her father was a
grocery and he was ultimately the mayor
of grantham so he was
a well-known man in grantham but he but
in the world of
westminster and uh belgravia and the
great and the good and the dukes of the
rich and everything
they have they've looked upon her as a
ludicrous figure
i mean some you know some jumped up uh
battle axe from the midlands and and and
uh and she was never particularly
self-conscious about that
but it must be said she was always a
little awkward and in that way
i had a kind of a past because i wasn't
part of that
awful class system in britain i wasn't
anything i was
like from another planet but i have to
say this better she
she did not have a good sense of humor
uh
she she occasionally said funny things
but she wasn't she wasn't a naturally
humorous person
uh which is not the end of the world but
it's it's nice if you've got a better
sense of humor
and um and she was a little
oversimplified in the view sometimes i
mean
the fact is when you get right down to
it uh
she didn't like europe because
she didn't like the main european
nationalities
i mean the germans in the french she
didn't mind the italians but she
couldn't take the italians seriously
but but but she rather liked them but um
but she she never forgave the germans
for the war and she
and she thought the french were were
sharpers and and sly
cunning and devious people and and um
she sort of worked in stereotypes you
know now if she met an individual person
from germany or france obviously
perfectly polite to them but
fundamentally she didn't trust either of
those countries
and she didn't feel it was really
europe's job
to to lead the danes and the dutch and
all these smaller countries that wanted
britain in to help them
and um she rather liked the americans
and and and she never forgot and she
told me this many times she never forgot
what the united states did in world war
ii how desperate britain's condition was
and and uh how uh
overwhelmingly helpful uh
the americans were she had great
admiration for roosevelt and she
she said and each year from 1942
we'd see more and more of the americans
in britain
and i know there were there were
frictions here and there and things but
to us it was just wonderfully reassuring
more and more these big tall strong
american boys would arrive ready to
invade europe
and uh um she was a
her family were practicing methodists
and every sunday they would invite
an american servicemen for that they
would see in the church service to come
back with them to have lunch say they
thought it was a nice thing to do to
young men overseas or missing their
families and so on to show some
hospitality
i mean she was a very genuine
traditional low church protestant but
tolerant
no no religious animosities of any kind
most of her constituents were jewish and
and um
uh and and just straight what you saw
was what you
got you know but very strong good
well-rounded leader but if
if what you need which is what they did
need
was someone to make radical change and
and say the lady is not returning and
this
is what we have a mandate to do and
we're going to do it
she was the perfect leader once you've
got into a
a subtler situation uh that would that
would not be your forte i mean she you
wouldn't confuse her with israeli or
something i mean she
if she'd gone to the congress of berlin
instead of israeli uh
they would have ended up at war with
bismarck you know i mean she
probably started starting as soon as her
train left
but uh but but you know with horses for
courses and she was a wonderful leader
for the time
as a person she was an outstanding
person
absolutely loyal i have great admiration
great admiration and for dennis too you
knew reagan as well
i did not as well but i knew him yeah i
knew him i knew him before he was
president my name was president and
after he was president and what were
your impressions of him
uh a a extremely formidable man
he was to start with one of the most
charming men i've ever met i mean
practically all politicians
are reasonably uh charming when they put
their minds to otherwise they're in the
wrong business but uh
he was he was disarmingly
uh pleasant without being staggering or
over-ingenuous
he was just a charming guy good wrecked
ontario terrific wreck under there
just very good conversation and uh i
i think he was a great leader i either i
don't i don't really doubt about that he
was a wonderful speaker
he kept it to a few basic points he he
vulgarized him mr friends say made these
complicated issues
simple and and it was almost impossible
is that something he shared with
thatcher that capability
yeah yes uh and but in a slightly
different way he had a more
he would throw in a humorous aspect that
was disarming
uh and and and he would also um
uh he'd he'd make it a a little more
anecdotal and folksy
she would've been but not not not where
his argument deteriorated
he was a very skillful debater if if
you're interested in this you can
find on the internet the debate he had
with robert kennedy
over that business about the left-wing
academic in new jersey
genovesa where he was at far left and
was a dispute about his ability to
remain at a state university because he
was a
communist and um and at the end of it
robert kennedy said don't ever put me
into a debate with that guy again
i mean reagan i had some conversations
with him where i was astounded
even you know well after he was
president and was supposedly in decline
where he had an astounding recall of the
details of things he was a
much more comprehensively intelligent
person and was widely known
because he he sometimes seemed
flat-footed
when when a direct question was put to
him you know the
american tradition is not one of
debating like it is in the parliamentary
tradition
i mean he was a governor and then the
president and he never debated with
anybody other than when he chose to was
with
kennedy here when he actually was in the
elections and
but but he this idea that he he was a
you know what did clark clifford call
him an amiable
dunce or something he yeah i knew
clifford too and reagan was the smartest
clipper
a different type of intelligence but he
was a very intelligent man
there was he he was in a way an
inspirational figure
because in his life he only had six jobs
he was a
a life uh you know a
guardian of for people swimming whatever
illinois and then he was a baseball
announcer in
des moines iowa california bound in the
great depression
and then a screen actor including i
think six terms instead of the screen
actors guild but his job as an actor
and then he was the vice president for
public and personnel relations for
general electric corp
and then governor of california and
president of the united states
and and he only i believe in had four
elections he beat edmond g
brown who defeated richard nixon four
years before
by over a million votes and he defeated
jesse unrah
by over a million votes running for
reelection discovery beat
president jimmy carter by i think nine
million votes
and then walter mondale just died the
other day
by over 15 million votes i mean it just
it was just a
a very modest career it was a graduate
of eureka college
and and then and then he he
just went all the way up to the top of
the country and stayed there and he he
undoubtedly was a very good person so
from
from this but i've got to say this room
he wasn't mr nice guy he came across
brilliantly as mr nesca in that sense he
was a little like fdr he
came across a very charming nice guy but
but
uh you know ronald reagan didn't go to
the funerals of the people who
launched his career like alfred
bloomingdale and
justin dart and henry salvatore
you know nancy reagan for all her
peculiarities was a
very human person uh reagan had
wonderful human qualities i mean i don't
know if you or i if we had a
as general al haig said a round in the
chest and the collapsed lung would walk
into the
emergency room and say i hope you people
are all republicans the way he did i
mean it wasn't but he wasn't
for you know you know recording a film
there
he really did have a pull up his chest
but but he he
he was fixated on certain targets and
while he was always
he was always sort of pleasant to
everybody i i never
got the impression he was awash with
human sentiment
where in her way nancy was
and that way she was kind of his
ambassador to
you know let your hair down and be
spontaneous
yeah you sound like you were fond of her
too
yeah i didn't know her as well i thought
she was admirably devoted to him
i mean like there's something about that
california
thing that spooks me a [__] you know
she'd consult these uh
uh astrologers see seers and all of them
whatever works for you but that kind of
thing makes me a bit uneasy but
yeah she was very nice to you i have to
say whenever i met her she was very very
nice
like i have to say whenever i met her
hillary clinton was nice so i don't like
it politically
all right so you're back in britain
you're you're you're you're running the
telegraph
and you're you're also moving up through
the ranks of british society you're made
a
lord how did that come about well you
know if you own a big newspaper
you don't have to do very much for that
you know you just have to have your
party in office
or or indeed now you don't even have to
have that i i was
i was installed by blair but i was put
up by the conservative leader at the
time william hague
that that's basically an ex officio
thing my predecessor had it and his
predecessor was
you know that was lord lord lord
heartfelt immediately ahead of me and
prior to that lord cameras
and what did it mean to you and what
were the responsibilities that are
associated with it well it's what you
want to make out of it i i mean if they
if i hadn't had my career interrupted as
it was i i you know i would have
i came in as a active peer and i gave
a number of speeches my arrangement with
the conservative whips office was that i
would
not presume to advise the british on
their pensions or even their schools but
i'd speak on
foreign policy and alliance matters and
that's what i did
and that was at the time of the iraq war
uh
and when when incidentally uh blair
needed us
because you know while there are whips
in the house of commons who can normally
control the boats
it's a life appointment in in the lord
so you can do anything you want the
peers can get stuff there's nothing they
can do about it
and and blair needed the conservative
peers to support his policy
so he yeah he phoned a number of us
including me and and and we did support
him
uh but um um
it's the if it's a serious subject
it is the best debating forum in the
world
and you know it has this image of being
a bunch of
you know down at the heel probably drink
sodden descendants of people who
did brilliantly in 100 years war or
something that isn't what it is
it's it's the numbers fluctuates around
800 members now
they're a fixed number of about 100 that
are hereditaries
but apart from a few specific office
holders like the duke of norfolk as earl
marshall
and premier duke and the markets of
salisbury and a couple of others
the the the elected i'm sorry the
hereditary peers
are elected by other hereditaries so
they have a runoff too i mean my friend
lord rather mere owner of the daily mail
he
he he didn't win he was defeated by his
fellow
hereditaries lord rothschild jacob
rosschild
he didn't run but he didn't run because
he knew that he wouldn't win
and by by the way they should those are
two people who should be there they're
very good people
but they and then obviously influential
people
but the um uh
in a serious debate you know you
remember you have the previous chiefs of
the defense staff
you have the heads of the main
universities you have leading academics
asap briggs for example
you have um
cultural figures like uh andrew lloyd
webber yehudi menu
when i began um and
uh and you have the leaders of great
corporations the main
trade unions trade union congress and so
on
and uh senior cabinet officials i mean
when
when uh when i spoke
in the iraq war debate it was right
after
the the last previous defense secretary
and uh and prior to him the
last previous chief of the defense staff
field
marshall brammer and um
and the the way it works is
it's very fair the the uh
leaders of the parties and those lords
determine an issue to be debated
and if people in their groups want an
issue debated their support for it they
do that
so they meet and they agree i will give
this to make it let's say a
12-hour debate over several days
and then whoever
whoever leads and closes for each party
they're fixed and they within reason can
speak for as long as they want
the rest of the time is divided up
equally
between all of those who signed their
desire to speak
which isn't put in a public place i mean
public to the
people who have any business being in
the
palace of westminster not on the street
but you know
anyone who you know any peer going by
right i'll i'll speak of that
and and it's divided up equal
allocation of time there's a clock on
all of the four walls the
lord chancellor presides and you can see
your time
and and and you don't go over your time
there are no rude interruptions none of
that awful
name calling and barnyard imitations you
get nice comments and things
very polite and um and
and you sit down when you're finished
and and if you don't
uh the the the uh
there's a sort of an arc of lord
chancellor stands up
and at that point you you really have to
say and
and everyone does and and then when the
debate ends everyone goes to the piers
bar and it continues
but but on a serious subject you get
absolutely
brilliant speakers and and and uh and
it's it's just extremely well done it's
very what's the net effect on
on british policy it varies i mean
sometimes the government needs it and
there are always some members of the
government who sit massive lord so
frequently the attorney general for
example
because they always want an extremely
respected barrister as the attorney
general of the country
and and that person is likely not an mp
so you put him as the lords and that's
researcher um
but as a matter of fact as
the business of the country unfolds
generally speaking
the influence isn't great i mean they
may add an amendment here or there but
these are technical matters but the
times arise
when because there are no whips and
there is no discipline
i mean people vote how they want to vote
uh
their their the position of those awards
can be very important
then all of a sudden all of you know
when i was there and
i expect to get back to this one of
these days and all of a sudden your
phone's ringing
from you know some prominent figure in
the government you haven't heard from
for the last five years you know
they need your vote and
are the debates made available to the
public in any form other than principles
no no they're on television as the
government's ones yeah and of course
they're they're also
recorded and available to anyone who
wants them you know in written form
so all right so does your your empire
your media empire at this point is it
does it reach its peak with your
acquisition of the telegraph are you
growing no no we went on after that we
bought the chicago sun times
uh we bought the fairfax papers in
australia
very distinguished papers and then we
bought the southern papers in canada in
and founded the national post little
after that
and uh so at that point it was right in
there it was when it was at its height i
mean
and it was a big company in that
industry it wasn't a
big company compared to uh microsoft or
something but
it was a big company in that industry
so what's happening to your relationship
with canada while you're in
well you're in britain well i came back
often and i kept my house in
office here so i kept it up well you
know
i mean i come back a lot and spend the
practically the whole summer here um
so i uh you know it wasn't as if i was
absent altogether by any means and then
you know when we had all the papers here
and i'd see the papers
i'd be talking to my associates in one
business and another here all the time
it's in the united states a lot
in our headquarters was in new york so i
was moving around a lot you know
and i had homes in different cities
right art and are you pleased with the
way things are going at this point
in your life yeah i am now it was it was
a very difficult
patch and uh uh and it was it was very
difficult but uh
yes now i'm i'm i'm pleased with how
things are going and i have been for
for some years you know well sorry i i
wasn't i wasn't clear
when when when you're in your your the
stage of expansion that you just
described
yes yes although i started i started to
have real misgivings about the future of
the newspaper business
and and they were well-founded
misgivings but we had a
an exit strategy that was being um
conducted very successfully until as you
said in your intro that
those problems arise shall we talk about
that a little bit
okay so what happened
you you hit a peak that you you had you
were running this
incredibly influential company and
trouble started to brew
why and and what do you see when you
look back
well i i took a good look at the
internet and i just did not see how
newspapers could continue
as a growth industry and so although it
was painful and this was win uh
starting in the
let me see now starting it we're really
i in
starting in the early about the early
90s around 93
and so we we sold australia a very
handsome profit and had it arranged in a
way where it
came through with no capital gain
assessment on a that was a company we
bought basically out of bankruptcy
not because it wasn't a good company
it's just been over levered financially
so the
it was a financial problem rather than a
operational one
and um and then and then uh
i i where it really
where it really turned was with um
when i s i sold most of the canadian
newspapers to izzy asper israel asper
who who owned the global television
network
and um and
and and says and we were continuing to
do that we were rolling these papers out
and the idea is we keep the telegraph
and basically and some of the smaller
ones in the us that were particularly
profitable
if you've seen the movie groundhog day
uh punxsutawney
pennsylvania we own that paper 50
of its total revenues were pre-tax
profit it was a very rich paper
uh not a big paper but very profitable
and um
uh and that's where we were proceeding
when
when the legal problems arose i i mean
we were going to
distribute the money not as dividends
but buying in and cancelling shares out
of
you know in a way that was voluntary
people wouldn't be
you know they would tend to the shares
to us because our offer would be good
and um so we would compact the company
and keep some cash and reposition it in
different businesses but
before we got into the implementation
of the expensive part of that uh these
legal problems arose and
then the whole thing moved sideways and
downwards after that what did you see
on the horizon for newspapers that made
you uh nervous about the continued
viability of the business
i just didn't see how we could hold
the readers against the internet that
the incursions of the internet
would be irresistible
yeah we just didn't ultimately have a
defense against it
and we we tried various things you know
we ran we
you know we put up internet sites but
they were really just um
enticements to come into the physical
paper and
essentially that was the problem with
the newspaper industry's response
it it it put things on on the internet
unless you just give your content away
free
in which case you're eventually going to
go bankrupt uh
you're really in trying to entice people
to
to buy your product and pay for the huge
physical plants that print the papers
and the vast
networks distribute them and that was
the problem the internet
had no cost newsprint and no cost to
delivery
yeah well it's an also an incredibly
effective place to advertise
and um so uh
you know i mean my prognosis was right
and my remedy was right
the uh there were problems but they
weren't problems created by me
and what what caused the legal problems
well we're getting into a real jungle
here but essentially what happened was
that um
some activist shareholders who were
essentially in the green mail business
they would
they would buy into a company where they
saw that ultimately the value of it
could be greater
and then agitate for sale so they would
start stirring up shareholders and
creating scenes at the shareholders
meetings and things like this
well i never had any problem with the
shareholders meetings these meetings
right to the end i never had the
slightest problem winning any vote at
those meetings
but
what what they did was they exploited an
american
provision of the securities and exchange
act as as
amended that enabled them to
set up a special committee to review
what they were complaining about
which was that some of these people when
they bought assets from us
paid a a non-compete fee
to my associates and myself personally
and that's what this is done in that
business
and for example in canada uh when we
sold
to busy asper at the same time the sun
papers were for sale because i believe
maclean hunter had a cross media problem
where they they couldn't own the
television cable and the
newspaper in the same setting so you had
papers coming up for sale in calgary and
edmonton
and ottawa where
where we had paper so aspar wanted a
non-compete from us you say we wouldn't
then
take his money and go and buy another
paper hire everyone away from
the place we just left and and compete
with them so
that was a reasonable thing to do but
anyway we had people who complained and
said it shouldn't go to us
and now in the case of asper that didn't
go anywhere because he wrote me a letter
saying that he he wanted this and he
wanted it from us and there was no
ambiguity about that but
some of the cases in the u.s were more
ambiguous but
we could have managed all of that but
once it got going
the um uh this special committee
and its council discovered that an
associate of mine
had done some naughty things and in the
american manner having done the naughty
things he said all right look
i will give evidence against mr black
never mind that mr black had not done
any nutty things i'll give evidence
against him
if you will give me this deal you're
saying this was done through council
it's you know the plea bargain system
was completely uh
undermined the entire functioning of the
criminal justice system you know so this
was done
and so the next thing i knew we were we
were all being charged with things we
didn't do and i've
ultimately been found not to have done
but meanwhile i you know took
uh 15 years of my life to get rid of it
all and the asset was destroyed
everything we'd all worked 30 years to
build was reduced to nothing to
bankruptcy
you know and which incidentally meant
that uh
more than one and a half billion dollars
of shareholder value in the hands of
people other than ourselves
just evaporated that was the singular
and supreme
triumph of the of the um
you know the shareholder governance
movement there's a complete fraud
there's a bunch of self-righteous
hypocrites taking fees for themselves
and ruining companies
how did you how did you survive it
what enabled you to stay well well to
stay functional enough to serve as a
tutor for example
well i i know i i knew that i had not in
fact broken the law so i was
fighting the good fight of the of the
wrongfully accused i was an
and i'm not innocent as a person but in
terms of the criminal statutes of the
united states i was certainly innocent
so i
so i had the moral righteousness to
fight
and i had the historic knowledge that
the alternative to fighting was to be
just absolutely eliminated in every
respect except physically
and conceivably in that way too i just
lost heart altogether i'd
lose the will to live so you have to
fight you said no you know it's the
cornered
it's the cornered animal you have to
fight or you're going to be
you know wiped out and um
and then and then
in the area i think you're getting at
maintenance and morale
you know it was very difficult at times
but um
i'm of that deal that believes that
essentially life is a privilege
and and that you make the most of it
however bad it is and unless you're
you're
terminally ill in a death door you can
always
derive some satisfaction from the
privilege of life even if it's
just going outside breathing the fresh
air and looking at a blue sky
and seeing you know leafy trees moving
around in the breeze it's still
it's wonderful when you compare it to
nothing which is the alternative
and um and so there is a duty to carry
on and
and both my experience individually and
as an observer and
such uh acquaintances i have with
history shows that fortunes change
and if you you know if you can persevere
long enough you come through things and
live to fight another day so yeah i mean
it sounds
and no no i wouldn't i wouldn't say so
not when it's not when it's acted out in
reality and you said that
you're you're satisfied with your life
at the moment that it's
it's full and it's rich and oh it's good
now it's good now i know look
i'm i'm uh i'm following napoleon's
advice to regain lost territory in the
inverse
order of their loss so i'm i'm sort of
bootstrapping myself up in one way and
another but you know i look i have a new
i i have a new um perspective now that i
would not have had and i
look i'm not saying i i'm glad i went
through all i did but it had
it had its rewards and its rich
experiences including the ones you
mentioned about the uh
the prison uh but um
i would never have had the prominence as
a commentator that i do i have millions
and millions of readers in the united
states
and and and i'm astounded at how many
people read my stuff
and you know when i get invitations to
speak and go on tours and things and
you go out and you know when we're not
hobbled by a pandemic go out and
cruises in the mediterranean and talk to
people on the cruise ships and things
and uh and and it's also uh
you know when i when i when i when this
came upon me i'd written two books the
duplessy one and then one about
myself which was really just to
deal with accounts of my career that
uh that i considered not to be accurate
i was just setting the record straight i
didn't think they were
malicious i just didn't think they were
very informative so that's why i did it
but i had written two books only
and as you kindly mentioned that said
i've written eight since then
they've all been from modestly to very
successful and
and and i like being a writer and i
wouldn't i absolutely would not have had
the time to do it if i'd had to
uh be a functioning chief executive of a
2 billion a year sales company i mean it
is a it is a full-time job and you've
got to do it right
so when you when you look back
what do you think you did right if
you're there's lots of people who are
watching this
interview who are trying to put their
lives together in one way or another and
looking for guidance in in their
attempts to do that what
what is it that you've done or what is
it that you've seen other people do that
you admired that were successful that
were
was particularly was particularly
productive and useful and meaningful
let's say and maybe even
right well i i think people who
do what they have an aptitude to do are
much happier than that
unfortunately very large number of
people who are stuck in occupations they
don't like
uh so it's been my good fortune that
um either i was able to do what i
wanted to do and and had some aptitude
to do
i was able to make that choice or i i
locked into it i didn't realize
i had absolutely no idea that i had an
aptitude for it but as it turned out i
did
i mean i i it's like anything else i
guess
i had always assumed that
practically anybody who wrote a book of
history
really knew a lot about it
was competent writer and did a good job
well now that i've done some of them
i mean as you said i wrote a book about
president
franklin d roosevelt there's a vast
literature about roosevelt
and and some of the people have written
about him been very good but a lot of
them it's rubbish
absolute rubbish it's not well written
and it's not accurate and they miss a
lot of things it's even more so the case
with mr nixon it was so
terribly controversial and um
uh and and indeed the reason i wrote
about those two men was to fill
a gap i never write where i think i have
nothing to add
i felt that roosevelt was divided
between worshipers
and the these people uttering this
nonsense about him being a communist
trader that was class who gave eastern
europe a way to stalin all this kind of
nonsense
and and and the thing to do was was to
put it out he was neither a saintly man
or a communist
he was extremely important and capable
and talented
political leader and leader of
government but but
for for the reasons i enumerated not not
out of can't and emotionalism
and with mr nixon i mean he was
just pilloried as a essentially a man
with a
clothing feet and horns on his head you
know and he wasn't he was very good
president
and um and by the way there's still no
probit of evidence that he committed to
crimes he admitted himself he made some
serious mistakes and
certainly some of the people in his
entourage committed crimes but there's
no evidence that he did
and and and this the one term that he
served was one of the most successful in
the history of the country
if you if you take into account that
when he came in there were 550
000 american draftees at the ends of the
earth with no exit plan
200 to 400 coming back dead every week
no relations with china no arms control
talks
riots everywhere in the u.s every week
all over the place he stopped all that
he was
very very good president anyway um
so it was reassuring to me that i could
actually do that because i had always
assumed before
that the people who did it did it
adequately well some of them do but a
lot of them don't
and there's always room for improvement
or almost always and um
uh sorry so i you know
gradually my horizons expanded and now
i'm
in finance and rebuilding my fortunes
somewhat but the exact opposite
to how i began in in business where i
mean as far as
anyone in the public would know where
because
i took over a company it was made famous
by very famous businessman e.p taylor
and bud mcdougall in particular
i was in the public eye all the time and
and as a young man it's naturally going
to be irritating to a lot of people
well now i'm not i mean i am up to a
point but as a commentator but
no one has a clue what business is at
are private and they're in different
countries and and to know
you know no one knows and and so i i
don't have that
problem wrestling with a public
relations
monster all the time and um uh
yeah i think you mentioned in one of the
books that i read that you
in retrospect wish that you would have
handled the public relations end of
things
i suppose in a more sophisticated manner
or earlier
that you didn't realize how critically
important it might be
is that am i recalling that accurately
is that effect
substantially so yes but my my my view
was
there's no way to avoid a lot of
attention so what i should do
is meet it head-on and at least
uh cause to be discarded the caricature
that all business people
are fundamentally stumble bums of
self-expression i can't actually give a
fluent explanation of what i'm doing
and secondly to advance the idea that
the business is in fact not just a bunch
of grubby businessmen
scruffing for cash it actually is an
interesting subject
and i thought i thought those were
correct premises and i was successful at
that but
but but where what you said is exactly
right is i
didn't i didn't appreciate as much as i
perhaps should have or would have if i
were more experienced
uh how tired people can get
of someone who doesn't have a natural
call in their attention
i think this incidentally was one of the
chief problems of the immediate former
president of the us
he he always believed i've known him a
long time
he always believed that there was no
such thing as bad publicity no matter
how apparently negative it was
well up to a point he was right but not
it wasn't right once he became president
because once he got to the
be that in roosevelt's phrase the head
of the american people
he didn't need the publicity and he
didn't he didn't want it and was
undignified for him to be seeking it let
alone for him to tolerate
so much of it to be baiting sessions
whereas where his enemies challenged him
and he responded
i mean he had reached a position where
you can safely rise above most of that
and just spoke when you have speak when
you have something to say
um i'm in my book about roosevelt
there's a little
piece and a letter he sent to someone
who'd been a colleague of his in the
wilson administration
where he was saying how how a president
has to
know when to be in front of the public
and when not
when it will irritate the public and
what not well i i wish
i had obviously never had a
position of one percent of the
consequence of being president of the us
but
i i wish i had taken that on board even
at the modest scale of where i was
um you know before i embark on a list
but but you know
part of the part of surviving and
growing older is you learn things
i think perhaps that's a good place to
stop
sure okay well i i've kept you too long
i hope uh
i hope either people find some of it
interesting or if not
they should put it on when when they're
afraid they may be suffering from
insomnia well look
thank you extremely for for talking with
me today and for
uh always a pleasure always a pleasure
jordan i appreciate it very much and
and and i hope we get to do it again
there's many things that we didn't talk
about i i didn't talk about
any of your opinions about current about
current affairs or
or or about the future or many things
that i would have liked to have
discussed but
we can do it another time if you want
great
[Music]
you